this airfield in southern france is a
microcosm of an aviation industry in
crisis
unused planes are sitting idle as
passenger traffic has collapsed during
the coronavirus pandemic
on the other side of these hangars
though startups making super fast trains
and driverless vehicles have moved in
former aviation engineers are trying to
build a future where they no longer like
planes
we do things that are at the edge of the
technology
even edgier than what you find sometimes
in the aviation
in a region that's also popular for its
wines this city of 1 million is the home
of airbus
as airbus expanded over the decades and
even surpassed boeing as the world's
largest plane maker last year
toulouse grew to become a global hub for
suppliers new technologies and aerospace
jobs
for one employer within airbus it means
for
us four employees here in toulouse
it's about 90 000 jobs
it's a lot but within a few months the
world stopped flying because of covert
19.
plane orders fell by more than
two-thirds and airbus has announced it
needs to cut about 5
000 jobs in france alone so can
innovation and start-ups save the
world's aviation capital from this
crisis
the old people would say that aviation
was born here
in this city near the spanish border an
inventor in the late 1800s tried to
build one of the very first powered
flying machines
and in the mid 60s a prototype of the
concorde the world's first supersonic
passenger plane was assembled here
airbus established to lose as its base
in the mid-70s
and has its headquarters as well as
multiple factories in the region
some 40 of all jobs here are linked to
the aviation industry
and the city's population has doubled in
size since airbus moved in
that growth only accelerated in recent
years
over the last 15 20 years despite the
crisis
september 11 2008 financial crisis
in fact there was no slowdown yambarbo
spent 38 years working airbus and is its
former head of innovation
so we were in a very steep ramp up and
and and
brutally everything stopped it's really
a catastrophe
i would say now he's the president of an
aviation industry group that wants to
help the city reduce its reliance on
airplanes
before the pandemic he set an ambitious
goal to create 40 000 jobs in and around
the aerospace sector by
got the financing for more than 600
projects
with a total budget of 1.6 billion
euros so you may say it's little
compared to the big
money at european level
but for the region it's important some
of that money is going to use here
at this former military airport that's
been transformed into an innovation hub
when we arrived on the site the site was
abandoned
since a few years now we have removed
all the bombs
everywhere we walk so it's safe now but
it was a funny situation when we arrived
hyperloop tt set up here rent free to
develop the world's first full-scale
test track for a futuristic train
that the company says could achieve
speeds of up to 760 miles per hour
they say it's the region's expertise
that brought them here when you start
this kind of project
it's new it's an innovation and you need
support of
people that believe it will work and
believe
you can do it here so we hired most of
them are coming from the aerospace
industry
they describe the hyperloop as a
commercial aircraft without wings
while the design remains in its early
testing phase the company has signed a
deal to deploy its technology in abu
dhabi
something that could bring jobs to
toulouse to develop the hyperloop and
bring it to certification
we will need engineers we will need
industrial capabilities
uh we will need a full supply chain we
will need testing
this represents a few thousands of high
qualified job positions
easy mile is another company that's
using frankenstein airport as an r
d lab they're using the site to test
their software that allows vehicles to
drive autonomously on fixed loops
like bus routes we do have uh former
aviation employees
we are in in toulouse because you have
that's also
an advantage of the ecosystem because of
the
aerospace industry we are using the same
kind of
yeah lots of similar technology the
company's doubled its staff every year
for the past four years
his self-driving software is already
being used around the world
and these vehicles could be
commercialized within two years
still none of the companies here employ
anywhere near as many as employees as
giants like airbus
and we are 250 people we're not going to
hire the 5 000 people available so we
need to be uh to be
to be reasonable on that obviously when
you compare it's not the
the same number of jobs many jobs will
be offered not the same amount
dominique fer is a local official in
charge of economic policies
i would lie if i would tell you that
tomorrow
they they will find a job industry
leaders fear that the current crisis
could lead to an 80
cut in production for airbus suppliers
and a wave of unemployment
aid from the french government is
expected to subsidise and protect many
jobs in the region for up to two years
still as it's expected to take far
longer than that for passenger traffic
to return to pre-pandemic levels
mass voluntary layoffs early retirement
and redundancies are likely to continue
given the scale of the crisis and the
share of our business that has
disappeared for the foreseeable future
there's still a need for adaptation and
blue collar workers are set to be hit
hardest
as many of these startups are looking to
hire white collar engineers
while production and factory jobs could
be somewhere else
what we don't know yet is will they
decide to
settle a manufacturing site here
even as globally 90 of startups fail
toulouse is hoping that some of these
projects could take hold
and grow here obviously not all of them
will survive
but some of them will develop and some
of them will
create really hundreds and thousands of
jobs
not now but in a few years that's clear